[موسيقى]
اعتداء على ما يقدس ازهاق لروح حرم قتلها
وتطاول على ذات الهيه تحيي وتميت
بحار اجمعت الاديان على كونه من كبائر
الذنوب والخطايا وادخلته المجتمعات دوائر
العار والصمت
اما الفلاسفه فانقسموا حوله العبثيون منهم
تحدثوا عن انسان سيد على حياته وعلى موته
قال هل تستحق الحياه عناء عيشها فعلا ونحن
نسال هل الانتحار هو ثمره حريه التصرف
بالجسد والمصير فعلا ام انه نتيجه عذاب
اليم وشعور بالياس او الذنب او انعدام
الفائده والمعنى ماذا عن السلوك الانتحاري
هل يمكن علاجه او تفادي الوقوع فيه وهل
زاد انتشاره في حياتنا العصريه في زمن
الفردنه والتواصل الرقمي لماذا يتنازل شخص
ما عن حقه في الحياه وما الذي يتركه
المنتحرون وراءهم في فلك الممنوع
لقد سئمت حان وقت الرحيل
[موسيقى]
لم يعد لدي شغف من الافضل ان تحترق بدلا
من ان تتلاشى
التجربه قاسيه وانا اضعف من ان اقاومها
سامحوني
[موسيقى]
فقدت كل شيء الا يقيني بطيبتك لا يمكنني
للاستمرار بافساد حياتك اكثر من ذلك
[موسيقى]
واخيرا اكون قد عبرت عن نفسي بالكامل
تلك كانت كلماتهما الاخيره قبل ان يسلموا
انفسهم للموت
لكن كثيرين منهم ينتحرون دون ان يتركوا
وراءهم رسائل وداع او تبرير
الانتحار من التابوهات التي لا تزال تقاوم
الزمن
الا حدود له جغرافيا ولا يمكن حصره في دين
او جنس او عرق او طبقه اجتماعيه
فهل هو حريه مطلقه في التصرف بالذات ام
انعكاس لياس عميق
بحسب منظمه الصحه العالميه ينهي حوالي 700
الف شخص حياتهم سنويا
77% منهم يعيشون في بلدان فقيره او متوسطه
الدخل
اما اعلم معدلات الانتحار فسجلت في القاره
الافريقيه كما يشكل الانتحار السبب الرابع
للوفاه في صفوف الشباب
وسط هذه الارقام والبيانات يعود السؤال
الاساسي ما الذي يدفع المراه الى قتل نفسه
سؤال يبقى غالبا بدون جواب بالنسبه
لعائلات تعيش خليطا من الصدمه والغضب
الشديد والذنب المؤلم
لكن الاطباء النفسيين اجابوا عن هذا
السؤال
[موسيقى]
للانتحار صله بالاضطرابات النفسيه
والعوامل لا تتوقف هنا
الكثير من حالات الانتحار تحدث في لحظات
الازمه
[موسيقى]
عندما تنهر قدره الانسان على التعامل مع
ضغوط الحياه
اما العنف وسوء المعامله والشعور بالعزله
فقد يدفع الانسان الى التفكير في الانتحار
عزله تعيشها الفئات الهشه والاقليات مثل
المثليين واللاجئين
بين وصمه العار التي تحيط بالانتحار
والديانات التي تحرم قتل الذات
فهل للمرء ان يختار بين الحياه والموت
[موسيقى]
الانتحار اذا في فلك الممنوع والبدايه من
القاهره مع صانعه المحتوى على مواقع
التواصل ايمان صبحي اهلا بك ايمانا انت
ناجيه من محاوله انتحار في عام 2016 ما
الذي دفعك الى هذه المحاوله وما الذي دفعك
الى الحديث عن هذا الموضوع اخبرينا اكثر
قصتك
القصه بدات الحقيقه من 2016 كنت لسه
متخرجه من الجامعه فكان
في صدمه اصلا ان انا متخرجه من الجامعه ان
انت بدات الحياه الحقيقيه وبعدين ما حادثه
وفاه حد من اصحابي كنت كديل القاضيه
بالنسبه لي ان انا ما اقدرش اكمل
فجالي اكتئاب لوقت طويل
حاولت الانتحار كذا مره
ممكن اقول دلوقتي بعد في فوايد سبع سنين
انه محاوله الانتحار ما كانتش حقيقيه
كانت
هدفها الحقيقي انه مش ان انا اموت او ان
انا اموت نفسي ولكن هدفها الحقيقي ان انا
اطلب المساعده من اللي حواليا وعبر عن
حزني لان شفت ان ما حدش شايف حزني فاعتقد
دي الحاجات المشتركه عند كل الناس اللي
بيحاولوا الانتحار عشان كده حسيت ان
تجربتي لازم اشاركها مع الناس بعد ما بدات
اعمل محتوى ايمان يعني في اللحظات التي
سبقت المحاولات محاولات يعني انهاء الحياه
عندما قررت الرحيل اخترتي ان ترحل عن هذه
الدنيا ما الذي يدور في ذهنك ما هي
الافكار التي تدور في ذهنك
كانت اهم فكره عندي انه انا وجودي مش مهم
وبحط ضغط على الناس اللي حوالي اكثر
من اهلي لاصحابي لان وجودي بالنسبه لهم
متعب لان انا مكتئبه ومش عارفه ومش عايزه
اعيش ثاني دي كانت الفكرتين الاساسيتين
تمام طيب دعيني فقط باختصار شديد قبل ان
اذهب الى ضيفتنا الثانيه برايك الانتحار
هو فعل شجاع ام جبان
اه ده سؤال مهم جدا
لازم اجاوب بكلمه واحده
طبعا الشجاع لماذا
لانه هو ضد الطبيعه البشريه الطبيعه
البشريه هي بتحافظ على حياتنا
زي طبيعه باقي الحيوانات
هي دي الطريقه
بتاعتنا بالضبط غريزه البقاء
فلما حد يعمل حاجه ضد الغريزه الاصليه فدي
بالنسبه لي شجاعه كبيره سنناقش هذا الامر
بالتفصيل بعد قليل دعيني فقط قبل ذلك اذهب
الى مكناس مع الناشطه في مجال التوعيه
بالصحه النفسيه جولنار زياني اهلا بك
جلنار اريد ان اسالك في البدايه عن تجربتك
الشخصيه ايضا مع السلوك الانتحاري حاولتي
ايضا انهاء حياتك اكثر من مره لماذا وهل
تعتبرين انك تمكنت من التخلص من الافكار
السوداء اليوم
بالنسبه
بالنسبه لي
[موسيقى]
خلاص
اكبر مني اكبر من اي شخص
عفوا
اذا تتحدثين عن الخلاص اعتقد اننا لدينا
مشكله صوت ساعود اليك بعد قليل جلنار
دعيني اذهب قبل ذلك الى بيروت مع رئيس
الجمعيه امبريس مياه عطوي اهلا بك ميرا
انت ايضا
اختصاصيه في علم النفس ولديك ابحاث في
مجال الصحه النفسيه في جمعيه امبرا
يستعملون على الوقايه من الانتحار ما الذي
دفعك الى الاهتمام بهذا الموضوع ومن هو
برايك الشخص الذي يلجا الى الانتحار هل
تتشابه الناس التي ترجع الى الانتحار ام
لا
نعم
بمجالنا بصحه نفسيه بلبنان تقريبا من عشر
سنين لليوم التمسنا مثل ما عم بيقولوا بعض
الضيوف اليوم معك على الحلقه انه موضوع
الصحه النفسيه بعده بمجتمعنا موضوع كتير
تبوك لكن هو كتير شائع بلبنان تقريبا 25%
حسب احصاءات قديمه جدا من اللبنانيين
يعانون من اضطرابات نفسيه ونتوقع ان هذه
الارقام زادت بالسنوات الاخيره ممكن تكون
وصلت ل 30 او
35% من الذين يعيشون بلبنان وبنعرف كمان
انه الاضطرابات النفسيه بحال لم تعالج
ووصلت لمرحله خطيره ممكن تسبب الانتحار
فالانتحار هو سبب طبيعي للوفاه في حال
كانت الامراض النفسيه شديده وموجوده وغير
معالجه فكان من المهم انه
اخصائيين نفسيين نعمل على مجال الصحه
النفسيه بلبنان انه نعمل كمان على موضوع
التوعيه حول الانتحار لنكسر الوصمه
الموجوده اليوم حول هذا الموضوع لنقدر
كمان نساعد عدد كبير من الاشخاص الذين
يفكرون بهذا الافكار ويعانون من امراض
نفسيه شديده بحاجه لعلاج ولتوعيه طيب
الذين يفكرون بالانتحار نعم يتشابهون
اكيد نحن بنعتبر بنشوف انه علميا بنعرف
90% من الاشخاص الذين يفكرون بالانتحار او
يحاولون او توافقون الانتحار يعانون من
اضطرابات نفسيه فبالتالي المرض النفسي هو
العامل اذا بدك الموجوده عند كل الاشخاص
الذين بيفكروا بالانتحار ليه المشترك لكن
في اكيد عوامل خارجيه اجتماعيه وبيئيه
تختلف من شخص وبيولوجيه كمان تختلف من شخص
لشخص ممكن كمان تكون حافز او تطفش الشخص
كمان للوصول لهذه المرحله تمام شكرا
ابقي نعود الى جولنار جولنار تحدثتي عن عن
فكره الخلاص بسبب يعني الالم الذي يواجهك
في حياتك اليوميه على المستوى على المستوى
الصحه النفسيه
بالنسبه اليك عندما كنت تبحثين عن هذا
الخلاص لا لم تكوني تخافي من الموت بتاتا
يعني فكره الموت او انتهاء الحياه لا
تخيفك عندما تقدمين على هذه الخطوه
في الحقيقه في المره الاولى كانت القضيه
صعبه علينا
دائما عايشه معايا
كل مره
دائما عندي فكره الانتقال يعني دائما
قائمه
الاولى في السنه الاولى على الانتحار كانت
كان هناك شيئا من الخوف ضروري ولكن
من بعد
بالعكس
المحاوله التي فشلت المنتصره مع الموت
فكانت الفكره من بعد ان الموت
الطمانينه التي
في الحياه
ولذلك حاولتي من المره الثانيه والثالثه
[موسيقى]
للاسف للاسف تقولين للاسف انهم لم ينجحوا
يا جولنار لاننا تعرفنا عليك على اي حال
ونتمنى لك يعني حياه طويله ومديده وفيها
كل الصحه والشفاء دعيني اذهب الى الرباط
مع الاستاذ في الفلسفه هذه معزوزه اهلا بك
استاذ هادي وشكرا على حضورك اليوم
الانتحار من الاشكاليات الفلسفيه الكبرى
لانه يسائل الحياه والموت في انن معا هلا
شرحت لنا بشكل مبسط هذه الاشكاليه بعيون
الفلسفه هل يمكن لاي شخص لاي انسان ان يصل
الى الانتحار
اود بدايه ان اتقدم بالشكر الجزيل لك
الاخت ميساء وايضا لكل المستمعين سابدا
بتعريف اشكالي للانتحار او قول اشكاليه
عفوا ترى ان الانتحار الفعل جبان لكنه
يتطلب الكثير من الشجاعه وكما نعلم فان
هناك علاقه تناقض بين الجبن وبين الشجاعه
المنتحر جبان لماذا لانه يريد ان ينسلس من
المشاكل التي يعيشها وايضا من الضغوطات
التي يعيش على ايقاعها ولكنه ايضا شجاعه
لانه لا يفكر في الانتحار وانما يفكر في
تنفيذ الانتحار اي انه ينتقل من مرحله
التفكير الى مرحله تنفيذ وكما نعلم فهي
مرحله شجاعه فمن منا مثلا يمتلك الشجاعه
على ان يضع حدا لحياته
ايجابي بالندم ودون ان يشعر ايضا بالتانيب
يعني كي لا يفهم اننا في الشجاع امرا
سلبيه لماذا لماذا تفضل
لا انا انا هنا اتكلم عن الشجاعه السلبيه
ولا اتكلم عن الشجاعه الايجابيه مثلا شخص
شخص مثلا يدخن هو في الاصل ينتحر ولكنه
ينتحر ببطء شخص مثلا يتعاطى الى المخدرات
ايضا هو شخص ينتحر وفي نفس الوقت شخص يفكر
في الانتحار جراء الضغوطات فهو جبن لانه
يهرب ولكنها شجاعه سلبيه وليست شجاعه
ايجابيه اذن هناك فرق بين ما هو ايجابي
وايضا ما هو سلبي في الشجاعه بالنسبه
للانتحار اذا اردنا ان نقدم تعريفا جامعا
لا سنقول انه هو نقطه لا عوده او نقطه
فقدان الامل او نقطه الانحار او نقطه
الوصول الى ذلك السقوط النهائي هنا استحضر
قصه رائعه حدثت لحكيم الا وهو بوده كانت
هناك سيده فقدت ابنها وكانت فقط ذلك الابن
ولما فقدت ذلك الابن اصبحت تفكر في
الانتحار وبدت لها الحياه سوداء وقد سقطت
في مشكل نفسها ثم ذهبت الى بوده وقالت له
العباره التاليه كون ان الحياه
الحياه غير عادله لماذا لانها تعطينا
الالام وارى ان الحل في التخلص من هذا
الالم هو الانتحار فقال لها بوده ساحي
ابنك ولكن بشرط فقالت له ما هو هذا الشرط
فقال لها هناك اسره تعيش في هذه المنطقه
اساليها
انها لم تجرب ذات يوم طعم الموت فاذا
وجدتها فاني ساحيي ابنك ولكن
شريطه زمنيه محدده
ذهبت عند الاسره الاولى والثانيه والثالثه
والرابعه فوجدت ان كل الاسر عانت ذات يوم
من مشكل فقدان ومن مشكل الموت ثم عادت
اليه فقال لها انا لا يمكن ان احيي
الاموات فقد اردت ان اقول لك اننا كلنا
نعيش ماساه وايضا نعيش لحظات مفرحه اذا
فلماذا نفكر دائما في الهروب في حين ان
الحياه هي مزيج بين الجانب الايجابي وايضا
بين الجانب السلبي شكرا لك كاميرا في
الفلك الممنوع جلد في شوارع عده عواصم
عربيه وسالت المواطنات والمواطنين عن
مقارباتهن ومقاربتهم للانتحار اليكن
واليكم الاجابات
من الواقع اللي هو عايشه مثلا قصه حب او
حاجه عاطفيه
خالص يخلي شخص ينتحر وحوش حل انت حلول
حاول يمارس الرياضه
يراجع طبيب نفسي
قيمه عند ربنا فانت بتقدرش ترمي بنفسك انت
لتهلكه وحاجه محرمه عند الاديان كلها
محدش عاقل مؤمن ينتحر مع ناس هذوما اللي
يقدموا على الانتحاب انت عاطف مع مريض
مريض مش تحكي لي على انسان ضغطت عليه
الحياه صغار ودار وكذا مجتمع خدمه قروضات
حب السيليكون ما انت عاطفش مع اقتراح
شخصيه مواجهش الدنيا ربي سبحانه خلقنا في
الدنيا هذه باش نواجه نصبر نمتحنو رواحنا
كما يبتلينا باش يفرج علينا
تحدثت منذ قليل عن الوصمه عن اريد ان
اتحدث قليلا معك عن نظره المجتمع هل تساهم
برايك نظره المجتمع هذا الشعور بالعار
ربما لدى العائله او المحيط الاجتماعي
الذي يتعرض الى هذا النوع من التجارب في
مساله الانتحار هل تزيد من حده هذا
التابوت وتجعله اكثر في دوائر مغلقه
وبالتالي يعني تزيد من من المشكله اساسا
هل يجب ان نتحدث عن انتحار من اجل ان يعني
تقل الاعداد او من اجل الوقايه
طبعا باي مرض لما نحكي عن اي مرض نفسي او
جسدي دائما التوعيه مهمه من اجل الوقايه
كل ما نحكي اكثر عن هذا الموضوع كرمال
الناس تقدر تتشجع اكثر انه تفتح هذا
الحديث بلبنان من عشر سنين تقريبا كان
الحديث عن موضوع الانتحار حديث صعب جدا
وحين اطلقنا الخط الوطني الساخن للدعم
النفسي والوقايه من الانتحار او خط الحياه
اليوم في لبنان الذي يعمل منذ خمس سنوات
بالتعاون مع البرنامج الوطني صحه النفسيه
بلبنان
الكثير قالوا لنا انه هذا الخط من سيتصل
عليه والناس غير
جاهزه للتحدث عن موضوع الانتحار لكن قدرنا
من خمس سنين لليوم نطلع من يمكن
يصلنا 30 40 30 بالشهر اليوم يصل اكثر من
1200 او 1300 اتصال يعني التوعيه ساهمت
بشكل كبير حتى الناس تقدر تحكي شكلها
واكيد لكن بعده اليوم اكيد موضوع الانتحار
وصمه بكثير من المجتمعات الرساله يلي عم
نحاول نوصلها من خلال عملنا اليوم بلبنان
هو انه حتى لو حكينا عن هذا الموضوع الشخص
لن ما راح تجيها الافكار اذا هو ما كان عم
تفكر بالموضوع واذا كان عم يفكر بهذا
الموضوع لحيث يتساعد انه يقدر يحصل على
المساعده النفسيه اللي هو بحاجره طيب
ايمان صبحي بالحديث عن هذه الوصفه
الاجتماعيه عن نظره المجتمع
يقال انه الشخص المؤمن ربما هو ابعد عن
اختيار انهاء الحياه من الشخص غير المؤمن
الى اي مدى هذا الامر صحيح وهل ربما
علاقتك الروحيه بالخالق كانت ستساعدك على
اجتياز المحنه لو كانت اقوى
في نص كل نص ساعه في الوطن العربي في شخص
بينجح ان هو يموت وطن عربي معروف
بان هو متدين عندنا اديان مختلفه كمان
وكلنا شعب متدين
فالارقام بتقول انه مالوش الموضوع ملوش
علاقه ابدا بالدين ولا ليه علاقه بالايمان
لانه المشاكل النفسيه اصلا ملهاش علاقه
بالموضوع ودائما
التخبط في في الفرق ما بين اه والله انت
بس محتاج تصلي ركعتين وتبقى كويس انك تبقى
متضايق شويه او قلقان وانك تبقى مكتئب
وعندك مشكله حقيقيه محتاجه علاج فرق كبير
جدا الناس محتاجه تدركه عشان نعرف نحل
المشكله اصلا لكن طول
المشكله بنحاول نحلها بان احنا نقوم نصلي
ركعتين ودي بالنسبه لي جزء كانت من مشكلتي
وجزء من الحاجات اللي خلتني احاول
الانتحار ان محدش كان بيفريديت مشاعري
وحزني بالعكس هو كان بيتقابل كل كل كل كل
اكتئابي كانت بتقابل بانه المفروض اقوم
اصلي والمفروض اقوم اقرا قران وانا متاكده
ان المشكله مش في السيره دي بربنا لكن
المشكله فيلز جوه دماغي فيها مشكله يعني
التي تشكل ايضا للاسف تبوه في الكثير من
المجتمعات في العالم حتى في الدول
المتقدمه مساله الاكتئاب والاضطرابات
الاخرى هي للاسف لا تزال تبوه طيب جولنار
اريد ان اسالك يعني اليوم
علاقه بالمحيط العلاقه بالعائله التي
تساعد الشخص الذي يعاني من سلوك انتحاري
ربما في تغيير هذا السلوك او في التخطي
هذا السلوك نحو
نحو امر اكثر ايجابيه كيف كانت دور محيطك
محيطك الاجتماعي في هذه المساله
في اخر
مرحله
اول حاجه سمعني ماما
لانني
المنتشر
الام والاخوه
والاحبه فهما من الانتحار
في الاخره
يعني انت اليوم في معركه مع الافكار
السوداء ونتمنى لك ان تربحي هذه المعركه
دائما يا جلنار اذهب اليك استاذ هادي
اليوم هناك نقاش طويل حول
يعني ارتباط الانتحار بتغيير نمط الحياه
في المجتمعات يعني اليوم المجتمعات ربما
تذهب اكثر الى الفردنه هناك تفكك اكثر
فيما كان يسمى القيم الاسريه او الاسره
التقليديه السابقا هناك مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي انماط جديده من التواصل بين
الناس برايك هل هذه التغييرات تؤثر على
سلوك الفرد وعلى نظره الفرد الى الحياه
والى الموت
بطبيعه الحال تؤثر ولكن هناك ايضا عوامل
اخرى هناك عوامل داخليه وخارجيه بالنسبه
للداخليه تتمثل فيما هو نفسي طبعا كعدم
الثقه في النفس او الشعور بالوحده وهناك
ايضا عوامل خارجيه
يلعب فيها ضغط المجتمع والعمل الدور
الكبير بالنسبه
لسؤالك ارى انه سؤال مشروع بطبيعه الحال
الحل هو انه ينقصنا مبدا التفكير ومبدا
العوده الى الذات هنا استحضر
مفهوم رائع ذكر
الفيلسوف الفرنسيه
يتحدث الو تفضل نسمعك تفضل
نسمعك انت ليس انت لا تسمعنا ربما تسمع
تفضل
لا اسمعك اسمعك الان قلت يتحدث
عن عن مفهوم رائع يسميه
الذاتي ماذا يعني بالرده الذاتي الرضا
الذاتي هو انني اعرف من انا واعرف ماذا
اريد وايضا ماذا املك المشكله في بعض
الاحيان هو اننا حينما نفكر بطريقه تفوق
الامكانيات التي نتوفر عليها انا اذن نسقط
في نسقط في المحظور نحس اننا اشخاص
وحيدون نحس اننا منعزلون عن الاخرين
المشكل الاكبر هو اننا نحس ان ما نعانيه
نحن لا يعانيه الاخرون اذا نعود الى ما
يسمى
[موسيقى]
المشاركه الافكار والمشاكل ديالنا مع
الاخرين بسبب نعم
التقاسم المشاركه
لا نشارك الافكار مع الاخرين نعتقد دائما
ان ما نعيشه نحن هو اسوا واثقل مما يعيشه
الاخرون السبب بطبيعه الحال هو اننا
منغمسون على انفسنا اننا نتقوقع ايضا على
انفسنا اذا المشكله دائما هي مشكله حوار
ومشكله عوده الى اصدقاء عوده الى الاسره
عوده الى الوسط ايضا ربما نمط الحياه
السريع الحياه الجديده يعني فيه الكثير من
من السوء في مساله المشاركه ومساله يعني
اعاده تعريف العلاقات من اول وجديد اريد
ان اسالك في هذا الاطار
سيده مياه عطوي يعني اليوم نتحدث كثيرا
عندما نتحدث عن الانتحار عن العائلات عن
عائلات من لا ينجو من الانتحار اليوم
الشخص الذي يموت بعد ان ينتحر
اليوم يترك وراءه عائله هذه العائله تعاني
من الوصمه التي تحدثت عنها منذ قليل ولكن
ايضا تعاني من من احساس اخر هي بحاجه ايضا
الى متابعه نفسيه عن ربما من النقمه على
هذا الشخص او من الغضب على هذا الشخص او
من وصفه بالاناني الى اي مدى هذا صحيح
والي مدى يجب اليوم ايضا ان يتم التركيز
على العائلات التي تفقد الناس بسبب
الانتحار
شغله ولا مره نحن التقينا بعائله فقدت حدا
للانتحار وشعرك بايمن المشاعر اللي
ذكرتيها لا يشعرون بالغضب لا يشعرون
بالنقمه واكيد ما بيصفوا هذا الشخص انه
اناني بالعكس مرحله الحداد يلي بيقطع فيها
بتقطع فيها العائله لما تخسر حدا للامتحار
مختلفه بشكل كثير كبير عن اي وفات تاني
لاي اسباب ثانيه وهذا الشيء اللي بنسمع من
العائلات يعني طبيعه الحداد وطبيعه هذه
الوفاه مختلفه جدا بالعكس في الكثير من
الشعور بالذنب في كثير من التساؤلات في
كثير من الحيره في
نسمع عند الاهالي بكثير من الاوقات الندم
يمكن لانه حسوا انه في شيء كانوا لازم
يعملوه اكثر او يوقفوا حد الشخص او يمكن
باوقات ما استدركوا درجه المعاناه يلي كان
عم يمرق فيها
فرد العائله لما
علماء يعني حصلت الوفاه فيعني الحداد معقد
جدا لدى هذه العائلات وهون اكيد منشجع نحن
على طلب المساعده اللي هو كمان صعب عليهم
بكثير مراحل ويستمر لسنوات وسنوات من بعد
الوفاه وهون يعني عن جد فعلا
اهميه كمان نقدر نوصل لهذه العائلات وتقدر
تحكي عن وجعها وتقدر هذه العائلات تعرف
انه موضوع الانتحار موضوع
طبي وصحي وما اذا بدك
الوصم الموجوده بالمجتمع بالعكس لازم
نخلقها لون مساحات امنه للحديث عن هذا
الموضوع تمام طيب تحدثتي عن الندم على
مستوى العائله اريد ان اسالك ايمان صبحي
من يحاول الانتحار اليوم
ويفشل او ينجو ينجو من الانتحار
هل يشعر بالندم شعرت بالندم
تقدر تبقى عندك
سبورتيف وقادر ان هو يدعمك تحس فيه نفسك
على طول على طول بترجع تندم انه الحمد لله
ان انا دايما ده اللي بحسه انه الحمد لله
ان انا ما مشيتش الحمد لله انا ما نجحتش
في المحاوله دي تمام
كنت هاخسر حاجات كتير جدا طبعا اكيد اكيد
نتمنى لك العمر الطويل ايضا ايمان اريد ان
اسال جولنار جول نار عندما
تقاربين الانتحار او انهاء الحياه تفكرين
في هذا الامر هل يخطر ببالك
البعض الديني ما تقوله الاديان ان جسدك
ليس ملكا لك انه ملك الخالق هل تفكرين
بهذا الامور ام انها غير موجوده بتاتا في
حساباتك
في الحقيقه
يحاسبني على انني لم اعد استطيع التحمل
اني نعيش في حياتي
ابدا
طيب تمام
اريد ان اذهب اليك يا استاذ هادي اليوم
عندما نربط بين الدين والانتحار والوصمه
هناك مثلا العديد من العائلات وفق تقارير
طبيه وايضا تقارير صحفيه تقول انها يعني
لا تفصح عن سبب وفاه ذويها او ابنائها
عندما ينتحرون لا يقال ان ابني او ابنه
انتحر او انتحرت برايك
لماذا لماذا يعني هذه الوصمه انه الموت
نقبله باشكال اخرى ولكننا نقبله عندما
يقوم الشخص نفسه بالقرار بانهاء حياته
هناك هناك سبب اول وسبب ثاني السبب الاول
يعود الى نظره المجتمع وسبب الثاني يعود
الى نظره الدين بالنسبه لسبب الاول الذي
يعود الى نظره المجتمع كما نعلم فان
الانتحار هو طابو اي انه موضوع لا يناقش
لا في الاسر ولا مع الناس ولا في التجمعات
ولا ايضا في البرامج المدرسيه هنا اشتغل
الفرصه واتساءل هل فعلا فكرت دوله عربيه
على سبيل المثال من ان تجعل مفهوم
الانتحار مفهوما يناقش داخل المدارس اي
انه يمكن ان نقوم بحملات تحسيسيه
للمراهقين وايضا للاطفال بالنسبه للنظره
الثانيه او السبب الثاني اللي هو السبب
الديني كما نعلم فان الدين يحرم الانتحار
لسبب بسيط يكمن في ان الشخص لا يملك حياته
وانما هو امانه
لدى السماء بغض النظر عن اي ديانه لان
الديانات هنا كلها تشترك في مساله في
مساله تحريم وايضا تجريم الانتحار لنفهم
ان الانتحار على المستوى الديني هو تمرد
على القدر وكما نعلم فان الله عندما يخلق
الانسان فانه يخلقه بقدره سواء كان هذا
القدر خيرا او شريرا اذا عندما يفكر
الانسان في الانتحار كانه يواجه ويحتج
احتجاجا ضمنيا على الاراده الالهيه التي
تضعه اما في القدر خيره او في القدر شره
مساله اخرى وهي مهمه هو الصراع بين الحياه
والدين يكمن في في نقطه اساس بالنسبه
للدين هو هو يفكر دائما خارج ما هو طبيعي
في حين ان الحياه تفكر في داخل ما هو
طبيعي ساوضح الامر اكثر
ما هو طبيعي يعني ان شخص عندما يتعرض
لضغوطات فانه يقول ان الحل هو الانتحار
ذكور اذا هنا يفكر بمساله طبيعيه واحد
زائد واحد
تعطينا اثنان بالنسبه للدين لا يفكر
بطريقه خارج الطبيعه وكما نعلم فان مجموع
الظواهر الطبيعيه عندما تفسر فانها تفسر
بطريقه خارج الطبيعه استحضر قصتين قصه
موسى مثلا اريد ان فقط لنوضح الفكره استاذ
هادي وعندما تكون خارج الطبيعه تقول انه
بفعل الايمان ربما الناس تؤمن بالمعجزه او
تؤمن بان الامور قد تاتيها من مكان اخر
لتتغير هذا ما تقصده
طبعا عندما نعود
تقول ان بعد العسر يسرا ولكن اليوم هناك
فتره فطره الحياه هي الاستمرار هي
المقاومه هي هي غريزه البقاء هل هذا صحيح
فلسفيا هل هذا صحيح هل الانسان فلسفيا في
المدارس الفلسفيه المعتمده التي تحدثت عن
الانتحار هل هذا صحيح الفطره هي هي غريزه
البقاء
طبعا مثلا شوبنهاور
مثلا يعطينا جرعه من اجل الحياه ولكن
عندما يفهمون
يدعون الى الانتحار وهذه فكره خاطئه
ساعطيك مثالا شخص مثلا قرر ان ينتحر ثم
وضع حبلا على عنقه واخذ القرار الا
تلاحظين انه في تلك اللحظه التي يرمي فيها
الكرسي الذي يقف عليه انه يمسك عنقه ويريد
ان يسحب الحبل او شخص مثلا اراد ان
من مساله الانتحار هي مساله مهمه جدا
اعتقد وساسالها لصاحبه الاختصاص من عطوه
مياه اليوم هناك يعني نسمع كثيرا
الناس تندم ربما لانها لم تسقي لمقربين
لها قالوا يوما ما ساقتل نفسي هل يجب ان
ناخذ على محمل الجد كل شخص يتحدث عن فكره
الانتحار او انه ينوي ان ينتحر او يفكر
فيها
طبعا ما في ما في شك انه لازم ناخذ هذا
الموضوع على محمل الجد ولازم نقدر نكون
نتعلم كيف نفتح حوار حساس ومتعاطف مع اي
شخص بيقولوا هالكلمات
وفي اشخاص كمان حتى ما بيقولوا هالكلمات
انه بلمحوا عن الموضوع بطرق غير مباشره
مثل تمن الموت مثل التعبير عن فقدان الامل
مثل انه يعبروا انه هن ما عندهم شي طمحوا
له بقى بالمستقبل وانه هم وصلوا لحيط
مسدود او انسداد بافق ما عم بيقدروا
ينظروا للحياه بطريقه ايجابيه او باي نوع
من الامل ففي طرق مباشره بالتعبير عن
النيه او الرغبه بالانتحاب وفي طرق غير
مباشره واثنين باهميه بعضهم ما في وحده
اهم من الثانيه اوقات العلامات الغير
واضحه كمان هي علامات خطيره ايضا
فهون كمان بنرجع بنركز على اهميه التوعيه
واهميه
الحديث عن هذا الموضوع بشكل منفتح
واخذ واخذ يعني هذا هذا الامر على محمل
الجد ولكن اريد ان اسالك ما هي يعني هل
هناك ربما علامات اخرى غير الكلام يمكن
للناس اليوم هل يمكن ان تفصل لنا
صحيح ممكن نشوف سلوكيات مختلفه مثل
الانعزال الانزواء عدم الرغبه بالمشاركه
بالنشاطات الاجتماعيه والحياتيه لهذا
الشخص كان ينخرط فيها قبل تراجع في الاداء
ان كان تراجع في الاداء العملي الوظيفي او
الاكاديمي او المدرسه حتى عند الاطفال
والمراهقين كمان اليوم عم نشوف نسبه
ارتفاع في محاوله الانتحار ممكن تغيير
بالنشاط يعني كمان
شخص
يكون في تعب زياده عدم الاهتمام بالمظهر
التخلي عن الممتلكات عدم الانخراط
الاجتماعي
كمان ممكن نشوف تصرفات متهوره او طائشه او
استخدام زائد للكحول المخدرات او سلوكيات
اخرى خارج شخصيه هذا الشخص لم يعتد
العائله والاصدقاء على رؤيتها تغييرات
مفاجئه في هذا في هذه الامور التي تحدثت
عنها طيب شكرا لك سيده اريد ان اسالك
جلنار ما هو اجمل ما في الحياه بالنسبه
اليك
اجمل حاجه في حياتي هي الانسانيه اول شيء
المخلوقات عن الارض انسان حيوان
ثاني حاجه بالنسبه لي انا
غريبه وهي الموسيقى
اذا هل تقولين لنا اليوم ان هناك ما يستحق
الحياه في هذه الدنيا ما يستحق ان تبقي
على قيد الحياه
على شيء
مثلا وجود الام وجود
الامور حديد الانساني
في الحياه
على هذه الكلمات اريد ان اختم مع ايمان
صبحي من القاهره ايمان اليوم ربما هناك من
يشاهدنا او يستمع الينا وقد فكر او فكرت
في الانتحار ماذا تقولين لي هؤلاء الاشخاص
احب اقول انه ده احساس طبيعي انك تبقى
مستنظف ونطاقتك تكون خلصانه وانك تبقى
حاسس بالاكتئاب ونتحس ان مفيش سبب انك
تعيش عشانه دي كلها احاسيس طبيعيه ولازم
نعيشها ولازم نختبرها
وبدل ما تاخد قرارات على اساس الاحاسيس
اللي هي اصلا طبيعيه
وتنتحر او او تدخل في اكتئاب وتنسحب من
الحياه
على طول روح لدكتور نفسي يساعدك لان دي مش
حاجه عيب ولان كلنا محتاجين مساعده واول
خطوه عشان
ما تاخدش خطوه دي الشريره دي ان هي خطوه
شريره جدا في النهايه ان انت تروح للدكتور
النفس
شكرا لك وشكرا لكل الضيوف نقاشي فلكي
ممنوع لا نهايه له نترك لك ولك حريه
التفكير وحريه الاختيار تابعونا في حلقات
جديده من برنامج الممنوع دائما على شاشه
واثير اذاعه مونتاكلو الدوليه تحياتي
[موسيقى]